special effects budget already blown
better use shadows
Dumbledore leaves Harry with dead
relatives knowing full well they will
abuse and mistreatment for years to come
there's no Harry Potter scar on this
imposter baby oh there it is guess the
makeup guys finally showed up on set um
snakes don't have eyelids movie hits the
bankers or trolls symbolism a little too
on the nose hey they said an owl a cat
or a toad but nobody said your magic
animal could be a rat Hermione isn't old
enough to be hot yet Harry switches
sides of the table in a matter of
seconds so Hogwarts is basically a
deathtrap turned into a school co-ed
dorms for 11 year olds Harry takes notes
and poetic couplets Snape takes points
from Gryffindor because a little kid who
just found out he's a wizard like a day
ago doesn't know all the answers to the
wizard questions Snape is a dick you
would not leave a group of eleven year
old students alone like this whether
they were wizards or not staircase
changes randomly at a time convenient to
the plot
hey bossy pants he said it right okay it
was Draco who said it wrong you nag why
are they running from a fucking cat Ron
is mouthing the lines that a mighty sing
they can't wave a wand and give a boy a
respectable set of teeth
Hermione runs all the way around the
giant Quidditch field in 30 seconds why
get the teachers use their magic to
decorate for Christmas so that Hagrid
doesn't have to do so much manual labor
see they even can use magic to decorate
the tree the restricted section of the
library isn't very restricted doesn't
the use of the lantern sort of negate
the benefits of the exist ability
exactly how tall is Harry supposed to be
I trust we do I realize it already or
doing you two clue where am I supposed
to go you didn't give me a letter to
wait they get in trouble for being out
late at night hang out with Hagrid and
their punishment is to go hang out late
at night with Hagrid also the punishment
involves taking four young students into
the forest so dangerous they have rules
about students going in there Ron
Hermione you'll come with me and then
they split them up
dude you are a wizard trying some magic
maybe your throw a stick tell me again
why people root for Harry Harry
this is where I leave you you just got
here you nitwit both will be strong
again I'll come back how is he in the
forest drinking unicorn blood and nearly
killing you but he's not already labeled
as bad Harry's glasses don't even need
lenses all the time
where's Harry scar when it'll be too
late and the bad guy will already be
down there totally awesome spell make
sure you never use it again particularly
with bad guys this camera angle is not
appropriate
don't worry wrong it'll disappear in a
minute see so the bad guy who beat them
here just left the key behind I really
don't think that should have heard him
that much
I mean he basically just fell down
listen if Harry's such a great wizard he
would have performed at least one spell
in this movie does the book explain how
the Sorcerer's Stone ends up in Harry's
pocket cuz the movies kind of all knew
about it wanted to find the stone that's
cute but it still doesn't explain how
the stone ended up in his fucking pocket
Dumbledore gives Ron 50 points for being
good at chess and not for you know his
bravery and self-sacrifice in the face
of death honestly I'm kind of with
Malfoy here slytherins getting screwed
why are the kids in Ravenclaw and
Hufflepuff throwing their hats in the
air like they want something oh I'm
gonna miss you too kid now run on back
to your abusive family
[Music]
when you can join me
Baltimore offers an empire but Harry
strikes back
this kid was the definitive blond child
villain until King Joffrey came along